there's more and it involves a woman who
normally is on the view anna navarro
she was on cnn i don't know how this
woman bounces around from network to
network with so little skill but they
keep putting her on uh and she got into
a little bit of a debate with jonah
goldberg about guns and again listen to
the way they need hysteria jonah tries
to explain hey there's other problems
other ways people can get killed but
hannah ain't having any of it switch
lanes you're absolutely right to be
outraged about the crime but if we're
going to tell people they should be
terrified about their kids being dropped
off at school we should remind them that
their kids are more in danger on the
drive to school
[Music]
a statistically life cannot be a
statistic right you can't tell the
parents of joaquin oliveira of parkland
you can't tell fred gutenberg you can't
tell me i'm making a basic point to say
that you shouldn't tell people that they
should be terrified if it were your
child it was not gonna it would not be a
statistic it would be a tragedy
why is it more i think moral [ __ ]
sounds as if i don't have compassion for
these people of
course that we i'm saying you shouldn't
tell americans you shouldn't tell the
audience that this is the thing that
they should be so terrified with
paralyzed with fear about their own kids
when their kids are more likely to die
from a lot of other things
pick up the phone and call their
senators and telling them that it's been
10 years in sandy hook and that we
haven't done anything is a national
shame so paralyzed with fear and
paralyzed with acceptance and
resignation is what we've been for the
last 10 years and it's enough of that no
more paralysis get your asses in gear
and call your senators that's fine i'm
doing analysis i am not doing activism
and if you want to tell everyone to call
their centers that's fine i haven't done
the point you've got a second okay
wait a second
or jonah goldberg trying to say
something true
on cable news well on cnn or msnbc and
it ain't easy of course he's right of
course he's right there's all sorts of
reasons psychologically and actually
factually that you wouldn't why you
wouldn't want to tell your children that
they're going to go out and get killed
when they go to school and everything
else the damage you could be doing to
these kids and anna navarro they this is
what they do with everything right you
overly emote the children are not a
statistic the children are not a
statistic he didn't say the children are
a statistic he was trying to talk about
actually how people die and what your
chances of getting shot are and
everything else but this is what they
and then they you know then they're very
enraged
and and jonah's lying that this is moral
bullying it was actually a great line
because that's what they do with
everything it's moral bullying she's
trying to imply that he doesn't care
about kids who are shot and that's not
what he's saying at all this is what
they absolutely do
you